S
THE PRESIDENT THINK SHE IS
LIVING AND IN THE ROOM?
>> I DON'T FIND THAT CONFUSING.
>>> THAT LOOKS PRETTY AWFUL.
EVEN THE MOB AND MEDIA WERE
ASKING QUESTIONS.
DOES ANYONE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEIR BOSS
IS A COGNITIVE WRECK?
HIS POLICIES ARE DESTROYING THE
COUNTRY.
HERE WITH THE REACTION IS LARRY
KUDLOW.
I SAW BIDEN'S BAND-AID SOLUTION
TO ARTIFICIALLY INCREASE SUPPLY
OF ENERGY OIL BY RELEASING THE
STRATEGIC PETROLEUM RESERVE IS.
I SAID AT THE TIME IT WAS A
BAND-AID.
I THINK IT WAS A NATIONAL
SECURITY RISK AS WELL.
NOW THAT I DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE
THAT THEY CAN RELEASE.
NOW OPEC IS VOWING TO CUT BACK
ON PRODUCTION.
WE WILL BE PAYING $150 PER
BARREL OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
OR MONTHS?
>> IT MAY NOT GET TO $150, BUT
IT'S REALLY A BAD STORY HERE.
WE ARE NOW, THE U.S., UNDER
BIDEN WHO TURNED THE FOSSIL FUEL
SPIGOTS OFF AND DROVE UP PRICES.
WE ARE DEPENDENT ONCE AGAIN ON
OPEC.
BY THE WAY, IT IS OPEC+.
IT'S THE SATURDAYS PLUS THE
RUSSIANS WHO ARE NOW GOING TO
CUT BACK PRODUCTION.
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY EXPECTS IN
THEIR MEETING TOMORROW.
OIL PRICES HAVE GONE UP ABOUT
$10 IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS.
IF THEY CUT BACK ON
2 MILLION BARRELS PER DAY, SEAN,
WHICH IS WHAT IS BEING DISCUSSED
BY INSIDERS, THAT WILL RAISE THE
PRICE OF OIL BY PROBABLY $15 OR
$20.
AND NOW IT WILL JACK UP GASOLINE
PRICES ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
NOT JUST ON THE WEST COAST WHERE
THEY ARE ALREADY TOO HIGH.
IT'S REALLY AN INCREDIBLE
MISCALCULATION FOR US TO BE PUT
BACK INTO THE STONE AGE WHERE WE
DEPEND AGAIN ON THE MIDDLE EAST,
OPEC COUNTRIES AND RUSSIA.
THAT IS ONLY POSSIBLE BECAUSE
BIDEN HAS TURNED OFF THE SPIGOT.
WE ARE PRODUCING ALMOST
3 MILLION BARRELS A DAY, SEAN.
LESS THAN WE WERE PRE-COVID,
PRE-PANDEMIC.
3 MILLION BARRELS A DAY LAST.
THAT IS A BAD STORY.
>> AND THEN HE WANTS TO DO A
DEAL WITH IRAN AND IS SENDING
EMISSARIES TO VENEZUELA.
ALL OF THIS WOULD BE EASILY
FIXABLE.
PEOPLE IN WESTERN EUROPE NOW
THAT FOOLISHLY GAVE INTO THEIR
CLIMATE ALARMISTS OVER THERE AND
ALLOWED THEMSELVES TO BECOME
DEPENDENT ON VLADIMIR PUTIN, IF
WE BECAME ENERGY DOMINANT OF
WOULD BE GOOD FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY, HIGH PAYING CAREER
JOBS IN THE ENERGY SECTOR.
IT WOULD LOWER THE PRICE AT THE
PUMP AND HELP LOWER INFLATION
SIGNIFICANTLY.
AND WE COULD GET REALLY RICH THE
WAY THE OPEC COUNTRIES ARE BY
PROVIDING ALL OF THE ENERGY
NEEDS OF OUR PARTNERS IN WESTERN
EUROPE.
BUT THAT'S NEVER GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEY WILL PROBABLY BE FREEZING
TO DEATH ALL WINTER.
>> WE HAD A CHANCE TO HAVE A
MASSIVE INCREASE IN EXPORTS, BUT
THAT WAS STOPPED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY WON'T GIVE ANY PERMITS.
THE STORY IS COMING OUT IN THE
WEST, THE INTERIOR DEPARTMENT
WON'T GIVE OUT PERMITS TO THE
VARIOUS NATIVE AMERICAN INDIAN
TRIBES WHO WANT THE PERMITS AND
WANT TO FRACK AND WANT TO DRILL.
THEIR LIVELIHOODS DEPEND ON IT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE GLOBAL STORY,
IT IS SO ANNOYING TO ME.
WE HAVE PUT OUR SECURITY BACK IN
THE HANDS OF THE SAUDI ARABIANS
AND NOW THE RUSSIANS AND NOW
OPEC.
WE SHOULD NEVER HAVE BEEN THERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
DONALD TRUMP HAD GIVEN US
INDEPENDENCE.
JOE BIDEN HAS GIVEN US BACK TO
DEPENDENCE AND IT'S A BAD STORY.
>> HE HAS EMBARRASSED US ON THE
WORLD STAGE BEGGING OPEC.
THEY REJECTED IT.
THEY HAVE